alles klar
super dann müssen wir sehen dass wir
relativ fix durchkommen das war schnell
arbeiten dann machen wir folgendes du
musst deine gemüse seite du musst du
machst gleich die aufbauten und du bist
ja jetzt gerade mal den zweiten tag hier
du musst einfach folgendes die höchst
vorne bei obst und nimmer los wir haben
ja heute die aktion mit den kirschen
sind ja auch ein sonderangebot für
sieben euro 29 das kind kommen jetzt
gerade frisch vom baum
sie müssen hier mit rein weil das war
wirklich wunderbar passt da guckst aber
trotzdem mal eben vor durch bei kirschen
sind sehr anfällig sie werden sehr
schnell schlecht kann natürlich sein
dass du die eine oder andere kirche
findest du packst das da nie vorne wo
die freie fläche ist dann musste dann
einfach die kirche norden
[Musik]
so
du guckst jetzt erst mal dass hier die
kartons einräumt das ist hier vorne das
regal eigentlich siehst du die ganzen
produkte wie findest du auf jeden fall
hat kleiner tipp wenn du gleich hier die
freie fläche hast ne schaust du gerade
nur aufs etikett die letzten zwei
ziffern hier von dieser langen nummer ja
sie stehen immer immer auf dem produkt
drauf hier
die 62 passiert mit dem etikett
herausgestellt
[Musik]